every country in every region of the
world has its own unique set of myths
and folklore these myths often feature
some quite disturbing creatures and
monsters and today we'll be taking a
look at ten of the most terrifying
creatures from around the world our
first creature is definitely one that a
spiked in recent popularity since the
release of the video game until dawn it
is of course the Windigo the Windigo is
a mythical creature that was believed to
have originated from Native American
mythology particularly from Algonquin
folklore one of the biggest groups of
Native American people the creatures
themselves were said to have been seen
in the northern forests in the great
lakes of both North America and Canada
it was a cannibalistic monster that
would feed on anything from animals to
humans in some cases the Wendigo was
thought to be an evil spirit that could
possess human beings causing them to
become monstrous cannibals of an
insatiable greed for our next creature
we travel to South Africa deep in the
Rockies Valdez eart where we encounter
the grootslang a creature that many
consider to be as old as the world
itself the grootslang is an enormous
serpentine elephant it somewhat
resembles a regular elephant but it has
a serpent tail and it resides in a cave
known as the wonder hole legend states
that the gods who created the group
slang made a grave error
they gave it incredible strength cunning
and intellect once the gods realize
their mistake they split the creature
into two creating the first elephants
and snakes despite their best efforts
the original grootslang managed to
escape and will then go on to Saye all
of the resulting grootslang the creature
was said to have a particular liking for
precious Germans particularly diamonds
despite its cruel nature it's believed
its victims could plead for mercy if
they're presented the beasts of enough
precious gems to satisfy its
never-ending greed there was a story
that follows the English businessman
Peter Grayson who in 1917 traveled to
South Africa in search for treasure in
the Rockies Valdez eart the businessman
went missing when members of his groups
were attacked and injured by lions this
prompted stories and legends that the
grootslang had killed him for attempting
to steal its treasure so we find
ourselves in yet another desert but this
time it is the Gobi Desert as we take a
look at the Mongolian Death Worm
the Gobi Desert is one of the harshest
the most unforgiving places on the earth
with huge temperature swings merciless
winds and of course acid spitting killer
worms the Mongolian Death Worm is
believed to have in a five foot tall
monster that not only spits fire and
acid but also electricity
merely touching the worm is said to
cause excruciating pain and sometimes
even death the worm itself lives
underground and is said to hibernate for
most of the year except for June and
July preferring to emerge from the
ground when it has rained and the ground
is wet the one most commonly preys on
camels frequently lain its eggs inside
of its victims intestines the Mongolian
Prime Minister of 1922 described the
worm as a giant sausage as it has no
legs or no hands and is red the acid the
worm spits can corrode pretty much
anything making it quite a predator from
distance however up close the worm is
capable of releasing an electrical
discharge sure enough to insta kill any
animal and even a fully grown human
making it one of the last things you'd
want to see if you're stranded in the
Gobi Desert it would be extremely hard
to complete this list so that mentioned
in any creatures from Japan so at number
four we have the Jorah Goomer the Spider
Woman the Jorah Gumo is a yokai that
takes the form of a spider
its name either translates to entangling
burden or horse spider as it is capable
of transforming itself into a beautiful
woman and Lauren men back to its lair
where it in tangles them in its web
until it's ready to devour them if the
dragon won't live by the muscles and
often make their nests in caves forests
and even abandoned houses in cities the
diet primarily consists of young
handsome men which they lower back to
their home trapping them in their silk
thread which is said to be so strong
that even a grown man is incapable of
escape and once entangled the men are
then injected of a venom making them
weaker day by day until they're ready to
feast on them
the jaraguá Hamas for deceivers no one
expects the beautiful girl-next-door to
be a man-eating spider Phonics creature
would travel to the locks of Scotland
and the rivers of Ireland or we find a
shape-shifting water spirit known as the
kelpie if the kelpie have been known to
take the form of a human but they most
commonly appear as black horses that
haunts lakes and rivers and they may at
first appear as a tame Pony but this is
nothing more than a clever ploy to
attract children and passers-by
once they're unaware victims are on its
back the kelpies clue like magical hide
makes it so they can never dismount
with their passengers now unable to
escape the kelpie then drags them down
into the water drowning them before
eventually eating them in the human form
the kelpie have been known to
materialize as beautiful young women
Lauren men to a watery grave
I'm say instead appear as a hairy human
that hides in the river if you ever
happen to come across a horse by a lake
or a river then I suggest you think
twice before approaching Inuit mythology
is something that we've yet to cover in
a channel but at number six we have the
qalupalik the qalupalik of human-like
creatures that live in the sea and they
are always mentioned as being female
they have long hair green skin long
fingernails we can almost look at them
as the inuit version of a mermaid the
legend states that they wear the same
pouch so the inuit people used to carry
their children the kalupia Cova do not
use this pouch to carry around their own
children but rather to carry around the
children that they steal away preferring
to target children who disobey their
parents and misbehave before the
creature has been known to appear they
make a humming sound which serves as an
early warning the children who do not
heed this warning would then be placed
in the creatures pouch and taken
underwater where they would live for
eternity never to see their parents
again it's like that this story was used
by parents to keep their children more
behaved than close to them at all times
a number seven we have the Aswang a
creature rooted in Filipino folklore the
Aswang is a shape-shifting monster that
has been derived from a combination of a
vampire a goal and a witch we can often
be found living in towns and villages as
a regular person they are quiet and very
shy a night when the coast is clear
they transform into a variety of
different creatures ranging from a bat
or a bird to a black dog or a cat they
only really transformed her in the
evening because that is when they are
most hungry they love to eat small
children and unborn fetuses with a
particular taste for the heart and the
liver some Aswang are even capable of
sucking children straight out of the
mother's womb while they sleep the
Aswang are most vulnerable during the
daytime as they lack the superhuman
strength are they possessed during their
nighttime transformation they can also
be repelled of the use of garlic salt
and religious artifacts such as a
crucifix or holy water
ancient Greece has some truly fantastic
mythological creatures and many of them
are indeed quite terrifying but the one
I've chosen today is the Linnaean Hydra
a gigantic nine headed water serpent
that resides in the swamps of Learner
rumored to guard one of the entrances to
the underworld the Hydra makes his list
not only because of its terrifying
appearance but because how difficult it
was to slay each time one of its heads
were chopped off two new heads would
take its place the Beast was eventually
by the Greek hero Heracles whenever he
cut off one of its heads he would
cauterize the wound with torch stopping
anything from spawning from the stump
eventually when he came across the loss
head which was believed to be
indestructible
he took a golden sword given to him by
Athena removed its head and then buried
it deep underground so the creature in
its head could never be reunited
Egyptian mythology doesn't have an
enormous selection of creatures or
monsters but the ones that did appear
were extremely feared it was known as a
devourer of the dead and would wait
alongside Anubis as a person's heart was
weighed against the feather of my heart
if the hearts were heavier than the
feather then amich would devour their
soul forcing him to die a second time
omits at the front hind of a lion the
lower half of a hippopotamus and the
head of a crocodile in ancient Egypt all
three of these animals were considered
man-eaters and none were more feared by
the Egyptian people the tenth and last
creature on today's list is the
skinwalker a Native American myth that
is common amongst the people of the
Navajo region the skinwalkers were able
to disguise themselves as animals either
through transformation or possession and
many consider them to be a type of which
animals at skinwalkers would most
commonly be seen as included foxes
wolves Eagles and owls but it's
important to note that they preferred
the form of a coyote as they were often
associated with witchcraft and trickery
a skinwalker can possess an animal by
looking into its eyes and it's believed
that that would often work for humans
too locking eyes and taking control of
your actions
once they possess or transform into an
animal they then possess all of that
animals qualities they can smell and see
things that regular humans could not and
they can cover vast amounts of terrain
in short amount of time there are some
rodents at the States much like a
werewolf a skinwalker can be killed by
calling them by their birth name we've
managed to cover a fair amount of
creatures from varying regions today and
this video has been more of an
introduction to each individual creature
rather than a full explanation if there
are any creatures in this video that you
would like to see in their own video or
perhaps you would like to see more
videos in a similar start of this one
then let me know in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
you